today's topic so YouTube has made a big
announcement YouTube commits 100 million
dollars to amplify black creators and
artists and I got very excited cuz
stimulus check you don't say you what's
the Worcester but what was the was there
was a downside who do I have to sell my
soul to so this is from the original
YouTube blog okay and there was one
thing that I really wanted to talk about
so this is how they plan on supporting
the black community we've always been
proud of we are a platform that
celebrates a broad diverse set of voices
okay and we have implemented many
policies that protect features and
policies and product features to protect
our communities but we recognize we need
to do more in particular with the black
community and that's why we are
committing to the following actions
amplifying black voices do you think
that's why we've been getting a boost in
subscribers now amplifying black voices
we're committed to doing better as a
platform to Center and amplify black
voices and perspectives today we're
announcing a multi-year 100 million
dollar fund dedicated to amplifying and
developing voices of black creators and
artists and their stories that you agree
with you agree with and one example of
the type of content we'd like to elevate
on the platform will premiere Saturday
June 13 or the June 13th yes we are the
youtubes will bring together creators
artists influential public figures and
prominent activist voices for roundtable
discussions and musical performances
with donations benefiting the equal
justice initiative I pretty much
guarantee you they're not gonna have too
many right wing words they're pretty
much guarantee but we'll see later on
today through the month of June our
spotlight channel will highlight racial
justice issues including the lady's
perspectives from black community on
YouTube alongside historical content
educational videos and protest coverage
you can already feel is gonna be biased
towards the left here's the part that
interests me protection from heat and
harassment we've taken many steps over
the years to protect diverse communities
from hate and harassment across the
platform including breck black creators
and artists and last year we developed
our most stringent hate speech and
harassment policies are up
it's policies especially bans videos
alleging that a group of racists appear
based on qualities like race gender
religion or sexual orientation in order
to justify discrimination segregation or
exclusion as a result of these changes
in our ongoing enforcement last quarter
alone we removed a hundred thousand
videos and a hundred million comments
for hate and harassment that is true I
don't get too many comments I say good
morning like I used to get that all the
time in my youtube notifications I don't
anymore that's it we know there's more
work to do
building on our work over the past
several years we're taking this moment
to examining how our policies and
products are working for everyone but
specifically for the black community and
close any gaps and more broadly we will
work to ensure that black users how you
doing breach artists and creators can
share their stories and be protected
from hateful white supremacist and
bullying content you guys remember when
Carlos Meza came out called out YouTube
YouTube immediately switched up the role
because they recognize it affects their
bottom line and what do they do then
acted all these policies about don't say
this you can't say that about this
community bla bla bla I mean just this
week we did a video where Reilly J
Dennis essentially said that biological
sex is not it's not a thing you know
basically it's mutable it's not a real
like stringent thing it just like we can
we didn't misgender her we didn't insult
her we didn't say anything we just said
no it is a real it is a reality there is
a scientific fact that these things are
immutable and that was flagged as
hateful it's hateful to say that you
know even in the most respectful way
that we could have had this discussion
in a disagreement because we stated
scientific facts it was deemed hateful
so while you're it feelings that book so
while you know they're talking about we
want to amplify black creators and it
sounds great for us today
I recognize that tomorrow they could
move on to the next group and then deem
us as undesirable so I would much rather
that this they just allow these opinions
to be said then for them to sit there
and be like no that's hateful based off
what your political leanings you banned
people who went against the World Health
Organization weeks out later the World
Health Organization says they were wrong
on a whole bunch of things so you place
whatever authority that you want as the
right one and then you say you're wrong
if you don't agree with this meanwhile
they themselves the authorities that you
claim a right or wrong on a lot of
issues so I can't trust your judgement
nor have you had a good track record
with a lot of these issues that's my
personal take on it you know what I
heard the whole time he was talking I
heard we're gonna do this to benefit you
if it really goes with what I'm trying
to do like it's not really just benefit
is if it goes with what we were trying
to do I'm not always I'm not I don't
always agree with with with people
that's meaning or right-leaning I don't
agree with a lot of people but I feel
like everybody should have like a fair
share of the cake now because I'm
dealing with YouTube right now I feel
some type of way about this I'm like
yeah I know you're lying you're lying
you're not gonna try to benefit if it
really falls into the characteristics of
what you're trying to do when you know
you're gonna be quick to call something
hate and be quick to call something
bullying in order to cancel it because
it was more with what you're saying so I
don't know I'll see I'm at that point
I'm not really big on believing
everything that someone says right away
oh yeah we're gonna do this and that to
me this this right there you just met
best politics to me he's like a
politician talking and saying is you
know well we're gonna do better for the
people in like mmm mm-hmm
yeah well we'll see what happens and
we'll see it unfold but as of right now
I'm not convinced am i negative with
that baby you know but I just see the
trend of what would be what has been
going on and now they've been doing
things so to be honest I'm not convinced
I'll see like the big headline is like
we have a hundred mil they're now gonna
start chucking out checks to people and
you know the initiative is gonna be
they're gonna put something
place that's gonna tally up to 100
millions business around they're not
gonna start to give money to people out
like that which is fine I mean why would
you know it's a business lot just like
anybody else it's a business before it's
anything else okay
so whenever you have in the month of
June you have businesses
yeah businesses with the rainbow flag
it's the business before it's anything
else the rainbow flag is not because
they're narrowly with that that's
because it's gonna bring them more
business okay whenever they do stuff for
like around the month of February
because of Black History Month before if
any type of thing that's gonna you know
push for good and it's a business before
all of that before anything good before
it's a business so yeah I'm not
convinced is it because I'm dead inside
maybe but it's also because I've seen
this happen and happen often and over
and over again I'm not optimistic about
the way YouTube is going about things it
seems to me that a lot of these
companies are doing this whole black
lives matter dance because it benefits
their bottom line but they aren't
applying policies that actually makes
sense or have a real impact they don't
they really don't and so when you sit
there you black we're gonna do all this
work your track record hasn't been great
and I don't expect it to get any better
going forward you sent me that article
yeah anyway oh we're about to get a
check I knew you were I knew what
sarcasm right away right away because
you're not good at this the odds would
have never been good at this when they
say black creators you know who they
meet like Francesca James would be like
well this is what systemic racism looks
like I'm just like nobody wants to see
these like bootleg buds phoebs ripoffs
go off here and be like where the black
craters of YouTube know you're a face of
it but you're not the face of it and
there's no such thing as the face of it
right you're just as much of this
platform just the way st. Anthony Brian
Logan is okay I don't agree with either
of you but I recognize that you guys are
both real black creators and when
YouTube says we're going to support
black creators what they're really
saying is we're going to support
specific people
I can't stand Candace oi I think she's
garbage regardless how I feel about her
I wouldn't support everything that she
says being flagged as hate just because
it disagrees with the consensus you send
me that stuff and you felt the ground
shaking that was me rolling my eyes so
bad right oh yeah this this is just mad
right but if you know Suzanne whoa Nikki
or whatever name is yeah oh I'm sorry is
that hateful I don't know to me just
disappointing now they're gonna have
this roundtable and I guarantee I'm
gonna pop into this roundtable that they
have today and it's mostly gonna be the
same type of voices you can predict
what's gonna happen so listen YouTube
can say whatever it wants to say they
can go the direction it wants to go but
I'm not gonna sit here as a black
creator be like oh my god we're about to
get paid or not yeah yeah well we'll see
like I said I guarantee you they're
gonna pick the button up black folks to
be the ones of the face of this thing
it's not going to be interesting but
that's my take what do you have any
lasting thoughts that's it leave your
comments below what do you think about
this initiative we want to hear your
thoughts whether or not you trust
YouTube to do the right thing
[Music]